good afternoon gentlemen feel free
because I do
it is my pleasure to have you here today
looking beautiful sweating it out having
successfully managed more or less your
first weekend here eagerly awaiting is
that the for the more or the less I
don't know what was that heard a little
shout out eagerly awaiting the start of
classes tomorrow as they did it the
second freshmen assembly I want to
recognize the transfer students who are
in attendance welcome I also want to
welcome those students who are joining
us for the year through the visiting
international student program as well as
those students there in the house
as well as those students who are
returning to college to the Eli Whitney
Scholars Program I am so happy you're
all here today as the majority of you
can attest the opening days of college
are filled with an overwhelming amount
of information acronyms appointments and
endless advice that runs along the lines
of do this do that but really don't do
this and definitely don't do that at
some point all this newness runs the
risk of turning into noise that you're
unable to process I recognize that this
event coming here the end of your fifth
day on campus and data overload could be
seen as one more information session I
want you to think of it in a different
way however at freshman keynote address
we invite a senior member of our faculty
to speak to the first-year students on a
topic of their choice there is a twist
here however the faculty we invite to
speak were just like you in college I
mean this more literally literally than
you can imagine the faculty we invite
graduated from Yale College who better
to offer you your first lecture at Yale
then someone who knows at an organic
level what it was like to sit here sit
where you are sitting to walk the same
path to class that you will walk
tomorrow with all of this in mind it is
my pleasure to introduce you to Beverly
gage professor of history director of
undergraduate studies in history and the
inaugural chair of our inaugural Faculty
Senate
professor gage is a historian of 20th
century American politics in society she
teaches courses on modern American
political history liberalism and
conservatism communism and an anti
communism and the craft of historical
writing
she is currently writing a major new
biography of former FBI director J Edgar
Hoover titled g-man J Edgar Hoover and
the American Century her first book the
day Wall Street exploded explored the
dramatic story of the 1920 bombing of
Wall Street and the history of early
20th century terrorism it is currently
in production as a documentary film for
broadcast on the American experience in
late 2015
professor gage writes widely for
publications including the New York
Times Washington Post the nation and
slate she has published scholarly
articles and reviews in the Journal of
American history the American historical
review the Journal of policy history
reviews in American history and so forth
she appears frequently on the PBS news
hour
among other outlets as a historical and
political commentator last year
professor gage discovered what one
scholar referred to as something of an
American history Holy Grail she was
working in the National Archives
conducting research for her current book
when she discovered the first fully
unredacted copy of a letter from the FBI
to Martin Luther King jr. in 1964 this
letter famously referred to as the
suicide letter because the author of the
FBI tried to convince King to kill
himself
this letter had never been seen in its
entirety beyond being a critical piece
of evidence that sheds light on how the
more paranoid niches in the federal
government viewed the civil-rights
leader this letter is a reminder of why
we come to a place like Yale we come
here to be part of a community of
thinkers who are never satisfied with
the stories that we inherit thinkers who
have an appetite to find out more to
seek out why and critically to explain
what they have found and its importance
professor gage is just that kind of
thinker and scholar she also happens to
be one of our most celebrated educators
receiving the Cyrillic off award for
teaching excellence in Yale College in
2009 most seriously though she happens
to be the mother of a very kind son who
happens to have as one of his best
friends my very kind son and together
they enjoy playing Minecraft playing
Super Smash Bros and a multitude of
other games I simply can't master ladies
and gentlemen a member of the Yale class
of 1990 for an American Studies major
who graduated magna [ __ ] laude and with
distinction and now an award-winning
historian who discovers Holy Grails
Beverly gage
well thank you Jonathan and thanks to
all of you for being here for yet one
more event in this heat thanks to all of
you the class of 2019
I should make no.1 note to what Jonathan
was saying about the Martin Luther King
letter that I discovered and wrote about
over the summer that I was actually not
the person who found the document that
it was actually my undergraduate
research assistant who happens to be
sitting here right now Jakob Wasserman
who was sitting there in the National
Archives taking photographs for me so
come Italy Jacob didn't know what he was
looking at but nonetheless he did take
the photograph of the document so I
realized in preparing this talk that
2015 marks the 25th anniversary of my
own start at Yale as a freshman I came
to Yale in 1990 so this was back in the
Dark Ages when there was a a smoking
section inside the library and be nobody
had an email account
realizing that 25 years have passed
since that moment of course makes me
feel a little bit old and I realize now
looking around that I am one of the few
people in the room who was even born in
1990 but it also makes me want to reach
back in time to my 18 year old self and
assure her that things were going to
turn out ok because that's not at all
how I felt when I was sitting here in
Woolsey Hall 25 years ago about to start
my first classes at Yale and that may or
may not be how all of you feel sitting
here today and some of the connections
between then and now or to put it
another way between there and here or
what I'm going to talk about today when
I arrived on the Yale campus 25 years
ago I immediately suspected that I was
not going to be a very good Yale student
I was a good student in the sense that
you are all presumably good students I
got good grades in high school and I
knew how to work hard when I had to
though I did not always necessarily work
as hard as I could and that was part of
being a good student too but I was not
sure that I would turn out to be a very
good Yale student and so let me explain
a bit about why that was from my first
moment on campus
I found myself confronted with what I've
come to think of as the three somewhat
contradictory messages that Yale
delivers to arriving freshmen the first
was a message of praise you alone among
thousands of talented wonderful
brilliant people who applied to Yale
have been selected for admission and
this means that each one of you is very
very special the second which you are
the second was a message of pressure you
are now surrounded by thousands of
talented wonderful brilliant people and
you had better step it up because this
isn't high school anymore and you're not
going to be the best one the third and I
think maybe the most difficult for me
was a message of privilege as the
talented brilliant wonderful person you
are you have been granted entry into one
of the world's wealthiest and most
exclusive clubs a place that will give
you access to global leaders and titans
of industry and famous artists and
writers and thinkers all because you are
now one of us frankly I did not know
what to think
about all of this and I came away from
my first days at Yale with a lot of
conflicting thoughts and emotions I was
excited to be here
thrilled about the opportunity that had
been handed to me and eager to meet my
classmates and my professors at the same
time I was nervous about the future
afraid that I would not live up to
expectations and wondering if maybe Yale
had a big blind spot when it came to its
own wealth and influence and privilege
so I did what I think many freshmen do
instead of plunging into campus life
and trying new things I started out
doing exactly what I knew I was good at
and I started out only doing those
things where I knew I could excel in my
case that was classical music I had
played the piano and the violin fairly
seriously in high school and I had done
some conducting and some singing and so
I started my life at Yale by signing up
for piano lessons and taking music
theory and joining chamber music
performance and that was that but
something curious happened over the
course of my freshman year here despite
all of my conflicted feelings despite
all of my worries I began to learn from
the people I encountered and from the
ideas that I was finding in class I
learned first of all that there was not
just one Yale that Yale was many
different things to many different
people and that this was actually the
whole point there were lots of people on
campus including I should mention the
Dean of the college and the president of
the University as you saw on Saturday
who had their own views about Yale's
strengths and weaknesses but who
nonetheless loved being here and sought
to make Yale the best place that it
could be I also learned that I was
fascinated by history and literature and
that despite my music centered schedule
those were the things that really got me
excited and so at the end of my freshman
year I gave my first ever and still only
solo piano recital in the je dining-hall
je
you're out there okay
and then I quit taking music lessons for
the rest of my life I came back as a
sophomore American Studies major and
began pursuing the ideas and subjects
that still define what I do today so
that was my freshman year I acknowledge
on one level that this is not a very
dramatic story
it can actually be summed up in three
words I switched majors but it didn't
feel nearly so simple at the time as I
was trying to make these decisions about
my own life and to sort out the
difference between what other people
expected of me and what I wanted for
myself it was a time when I often felt
lonely and confused and unsure about
what I should do next but it was also
exciting and more than that it was
entirely necessary a chance to break out
of old molds and try something new and
this is the message that I want you to
take away from these first few days on
campus Yale is above all an opportunity
to grow and learn and change and to
think seriously about who you are and
what you want freshman year is the time
that you get to start writing the story
of your own life
so now let's fast-forward 25 years I've
been back here at Yale teaching as a
professor of American history for more
than a decade and in that role I spend a
lot of time talking with students about
what I often described as the paradoxes
of history but about the blend of change
and continuity that makes up the human
past Dean Holloway and president
salivate talked about these themes on
Saturday in the context of Yale
and its relationship with slavery and
white supremacy today I would like to
encourage you to think about those
questions not as they apply to Yale but
as they apply to your own lives as a
professor here I teach a course on the
history of liberalism and conservatism
in the United States and we look in that
class about how those two terms change
over time and in some ways stay the same
and as part of that class I ask students
to write their political autobiographies
to think about why they hold the
political views that they do and to
imagine what larger forces in society
might have led them to this place this
is something we often do when we're
thinking about historical figures what
part is John Calhoun the man and what
part was simply the times in which he
lived
the region in which he was born his race
or religion or class or the political
views of his own family so I ask
students to turn that lens on themselves
and to think about forces outside of
their own individual ambition or
temperament or intellect that may have
shaped how they think about the world
and they end up writing about all sorts
of things some students write about
conversations around the dinner table
about their mother who made them listen
to NPR or their father who made them
watch Fox News others write about their
direct experiences say the difficulties
and rewards of being the only out gay
student in a conservative high school or
of being the quote/unquote scholarship
kid in a world of wealth sometimes since
this is Yale students write about
hanging out with their parents in the
White House
and watching politics unfold from the
top down
others write about their grassroots
experiences the thrills and
disappointments of working on a
political campaign or throwing their
energies into a movement for social
transformation so a lot of these papers
draw on early experiences elements of
childhood or even deeper back into
family history but one of the things
that has struck me most of all in
reading these papers has been how much
students change during their time at
Yale just for the record I don't mean
that they all become raging liberals
which is what many people in the outside
world would think actually happens
inside of Yale I mean that they and now
you change in all sorts of different
ways and find a vast range of new
experiences in the next four years some
of you who may run for local political
office or student government many of you
will probably vote for the first time
hopefully all of you will meet someone
who fundamentally challenges your
assumptions and either persuades you to
their cause or shows you how to
respectfully disagree some of you may
discover new aspects of your sexuality
or new extracurricular interests and
some of you may read a book or take a
class that significantly changes your
point of view whatever those experiences
may be the key is that they will happen
here that Yale changes and broadens and
transforms the people within its
community your job is to take all of
this in and then discard some of it
those parts that aren't useful or that
don't speak to you in meaningful ways
think of it as an editing process this
year you get to write a first draft of
your own Yale experience and
you have three more years to fine-tune
what you want to do and what you want to
say and at the end of it all you will
hopefully have a remarkable story of
your own to tell right the other thing
that professors do at Yale besides
teaching is that we conduct our own
research
well we actually also attend faculty
meetings and serve on committees but
since it's so hot in here I will not go
into elaborate descriptions of all of
that at the moment as Dean Holloway
mentioned my own research project is a
really big fat doorstop biography of j
edgar Hoover who was the director of the
FBI from 1924 to 1972 so a big chunk of
the 20th century 48 years often when I
tell people that I am writing a
biography of Hoover they say oh why
would you want to spend so much time
with such an awful man for those of you
who aren't familiar with Hoover's
reputation he's widely known as a kind
of tyrannical figure in Washington so
someone who was spying on everyone and
then using all of that information to
kind of cement his own political power
which is how he lasted 48 years in
office part of my task as a biographer
is to attempt to humanize this man and
to make him into more than just a
one-dimensional villain one of the ways
that I've tried to do this is to take
another look at his childhood and
especially his college years and to
think about how those early experiences
shaped the person he became for instance
he was born and bred in Washington DC in
a little house that was just five blocks
from the Capitol so he grew up in a
culture of government service
his father was mentally ill with what we
would today describe as something like
severe depression
so Hoover never had the chance to go
away to college and he attended night
school at home in Washington so that he
could stay nearby and earn money and
take care of his parents during college
he joined a fraternity called Kappa
Alpha which was a southern fraternity
founded explicitly to carry on
traditions of white supremacy and to
promote the values of the antebellum
slaveholding south so this was early
training in a kind of racialized
thinking that would ultimately have very
serious consequences for the entire
nation and then he happened to graduate
from college in 1917 at the very moment
that the United States was entering
World War one and so he stepped into a
government job because he was a boy in
Washington and the bureaucracy was
expanding and as it turned out he never
left he went to work at the Justice
Department at the age of 22 became head
of the FBI at 29 and died in that same
job at the age of 77 I tell this story
not to suggest that the first job you
take out of college will be the job that
you will have to hold for the rest of
your life instead I want to emphasize
that we are all of us even supposed
one-dimensional tyrants like Hoover at
once the products of the world into
which we are born or the organizations
we join in college and our own
individual ambitions and desires and
we'll there are already many factors
that have combined to put each of you on
your current path in life and there will
be many other factors often beyond your
control that shape where you end up
right now at this plastic moment in time
the day before your first
to college classes this is a moment to
sit back and reflect about what you want
and how you want to shape your own path
into the future
okay so now as I finish up I also want
to offer a few words of practical advice
I know you've been getting a lot of this
in recent days particularly before you
plunge into the strange and wonderful
experience known as Yale shopping period
all right point one don't go crazy there
are more than a thousand classes being
offered this semester at Yale and the
purpose of shopping period is not to
shock them all shopping period is really
great to try out classes where you think
you might be interested it's a wonderful
opportunity to experiment but it can
sometimes make people a little crazy if
they're running from class to class to
class so be selective about what you do
in the next few days leave room in your
schedule for something that you're doing
just because you want to do it but don't
go around to every single class because
the truth of the matter is that you
actually can't know what you're going to
get out of class until you've invested
something of yourself in it and that
process doesn't really begin until
shopping period is over
point to be selfish on Saturday Dean
Holloway asked you to thank your parents
and your teachers and the people from
your hometown for all they've done for
you all of which is wonderful but now
they are gone and I can offer a
different piece of advice which is to
forget about them don't really do that
entirely but make the choices that you
ultimately want to make here on campus
because you are the only one who is
living here and you are the only one who
is experiencing your own life number
three ask for help there's a lot you
still
no despite this week of activity about
how Yale works and that is how it should
be even if it seems like everyone around
you already knows everything I can tell
you with 100% certainty that they are
faking it so don't be afraid to ask even
basic information and for instance it
took me a long time as a freshman to
figure out the professor's really want
you to go to their office hours that
they hold office hours so you can stop
by they can get to know you and you can
have a real intellectual and personal
exchange I have one other little piece
of gathering information advice and I am
going to abuse my place up here on the
platform and Dean Holloway can't object
because he is also a historian in the
history department tomorrow night in the
history department we are holding a
shopping party for all undergraduates
who are interested in history to come
get to know us learn about our classes
meet new professors it's actually pretty
fun and you should all come to that
seven-day 30 HGS 2:11 I'm hosting ok you
should all come so even if history is
not your thing
you should get out there and explore
everything that's on offer in these next
couple of weeks as this information is
being offered to you and that includes
point number 4 there are only six in
total point number 4 explore New Haven
Yale can sometimes be a bubble or to put
it less charitably a fortress with big
iron gates that mark the difference
between being inside and being outside
but the city of New Haven is a place
that has a lot to teach all of you and
it's a city where your energies can
really make a difference when I was an
undergraduate I worked in New Haven as a
GED teacher I taught writing classes in
a women's prison and I interned at a
local newspaper and though I loved my
Yale class
is these other places taught me a great
deal as well
number five quit things this was what I
did and it was really great it was
absolutely the right choice or at least
quit the right things the ones that
aren't truly engaging your energies and
finally take care of yourself and I mean
this in two ways the first is the more
literal Yale tends to push people to do
more and faster and better to stay up
all night and then brag about how little
you slept and then wake up and sign up
for even more this is actually not a
good idea
the bigger challenge here is to find
some sort of balance in your life
to make sure that you have time to do
things like eat and sleep and read and
reflect and sometimes do nothing at all
so that's one way that I hope that you
will all take care of yourselves but I
also hope that during your four years
here you'll find a way to take care of
yourself that part of you that is more
than the sum total of accomplishments
and expectations and who you might
appear to be on paper these next four
years are a time to explore new ideas
and be remarkable new people and to
challenge yourselves in new ways part of
this means figuring out who you are and
who you want to be and what you want to
contribute to the world your four years
at Yale starting tomorrow are a chance
to throw out the old script and to write
your own story of your own life thank
you
this is a place as you're writing your
own life this is a place that you
discover you will discover has many
components to it that claim at least to
be timeless one of these is the song
bright college years known also as our
alma mater the glee club will help you
learn the alma mater this is a song that
that's your cue to come up are you guys
coming up on stage this is very well
rehearsed this is a song that they will
help you learn today and it will also be
a song you'll hear numerous times that
your Yale career and it'll be the last
song you sing together in May of 2019
even though I was not myself an
undergraduate here her the song quite a
bit in my 8 years of living in the
college the song strikes a deep chord
with me and I think it's actually quite
true the lyrics that that is hopefully
it will come to mean as much to you as
it does to this guy who didn't even come
to this school
the choir the club skews a Yale glee
club is going to sing the lyrics on the
back by the way he'll sing the first
verse by themselves they'll repeat that
first verse which you will then join and
reading the second verse the one last
piece of advice or direction on your
seats I believe you all have or you're
given this Yale 19 handkerchief I
actually don't know the history behind
this one it's charming well it's weird
the first time you see it then becomes
charming after a while in the closing
lines of into the second verse you'll
see for God for country and for Yale you
will take this handkerchief in your
right one left hand but we know in the
hand and you will go for God for country
and for Yale and you will wonder why and
you will feel awkward but there are a
thousand other people feeling awkward
with you at the same time it's your
first lesson in togetherness
ladies and gentlemen yell glee club
Jeffrey Douma in the Yale glee club
thank you very much you are now excused
wait don't move Hana
where's Hana you said you'd be in the is
there an order of excellent exit the
same way you came in enjoy your evening
have a lovely time at freshman dinner
and have a fabulous time in class
tomorrow